how do you create
barriers to entry it's a great question
one that came in from one of my
newsletter readers uh nazirki i hope i
pronounced that properly
and it's great because you need to have
something different about your business
right you got to have some way to stand
out if you're doing something different
then everybody copies you
if everybody's doing the same thing then
then it's again hard to stand out it's
hard to get people talking about it's
hard to drive more traffic
to your store to your website you know
it's hard to get people to buy from you
so nazerke wrote in uh saying you know
he's making a new product
and besides licensing how can you create
unfair competitive advantage
for other companies not to copy what
barriers can we create for competitors
to enter the market
thanks a lot so there's a couple main
ways to create barriers to entry for
your business
and a lot of them are not as easy to
achieve as others so let me go through
them
the first is a monopoly okay you own
everything so if you own all the trees
then somebody wants to buy trees they
have to go from you right they have to
buy from you
that model is super hard to do nowadays
right if you're if you're creating you
know apps and smartphones and ipad
apps how do you own the market you can't
the second thing is to have a patent so
you've created some new technology and
you patent it so that nobody else can
copy it
patents are great but
it's so easy especially with the
technology pattern it's so easy to
change one little thing
and companies can skirt their way around
the pack so they can still steal your
ideas they can still copy and put into
their business
it's still great to have especially if
you're going for funding or such as
you're trying to get acquired with your
business
the patent can be really helpful for you
it makes you look like you have some
momentum with your company
but at the end of the day competitors
are still going to get in and copy what
you're doing
the best way the third way in my opinion
to create this unfair advantage
is to pour yourself into your business
you think about what makes you different
think about why you're starting this
business so
the business here is uh apps for
disabled kids
to make their studies simple and fun why
do you want to do this
do you have a disabled kid were you
disabled when you were a child
what is driving this passion to help
disabled kids i think it's noble cause i
think it's great
i think there's a lot of opportunity but
why are you doing this
you need to pour yourself into your
business you need to make people want to
buy from you
and the experience that they get buying
from your business
what's the reason behind this thing how
can you make your creativity shine
through in what you're doing
that's something nobody else can copy
because nobody else is you
nobody else can make it personal the way
you can because that's your unique
experience
that's the way to stand out especially
in the competitive market
right how many ipad iphone apps are out
there
tons it's get it's growing by the second
it's crazy
how do you stand out most of the apps
are coming out are me too they're
copycats they're not unique they're not
creative they're not original and as a
result
nobody downloads them nobody buys it
nobody upgrades on them
the way to be unique be different have a
sustainable competitive advantage is to
pour yourself your heart your passion
into your business because nobody can
copy you for those of you watching if
you're in a competitive business and
most people are if you're a real estate
agent if you're a life insurance
agent if you're a technology developer
you have tons of competition you're a
real estate agent think of how many real
estate agents are out there
why should i hire you versus somebody
else you have to pour yourself
into it what do you stand for what do
you believe why are you doing this
because it's not to make money money
comes but there's something else there's
some reason that's driving you
and that's got to come through think
about my business
help entrepreneurs how many people help
entrepreneurs tons of people help
entrepreneurs
what's different about me why do you
guys come and watch my videos why do you
subscribe to my newsletter subscribe to
my youtube channel on twitter on
facebook
buy my worksheets why are you involved
in what i'm doing because it's me you
like what i
share i share my personal stories
i add my own touch to everything that
i'm doing if i try to be
exactly like somebody else it's not
gonna work somebody can't be
me if you wanted to help entrepreneurs
you couldn't do
exactly what i do you couldn't be evan
you have to be you you have to find your
own way to do it
that's where your success will come i
have a long term sustainable competitive
advantage
unfair advantage huge barriers to entry
because nobody else can be evan
carmichael
and that's the same thing you need to
bring to your business
you're not just making apps you're
throwing yourself into it and nobody
else can be you
that's your long-term advantage believe
those who watching like the video please
give it a thumbs up below it always
makes me want to do more for you and
please leave a comment below let me know
what you think
your comments drive me every day to want
to do more to help entrepreneurs you get
me motivated every day when i wake up
and read so please leave it below
leave a question let me know below too
i'll make a video response
thank you so much and i'll see you soon